RYAN LIPPERT: I'd like to
welcome everyone to our Google
Cloud Next OnAir session.
My name's Ryan Lippert, Product
Manager at Google Cloud.
And I'm going to be joined
by Daniel Lewis from Geotab.
Daniel is a Senior Data
Scientist and Research
Specialist for Geotab,
a company which
works in the telematics space.
That is instrumenting
vehicles to learn
how to optimize fleet
maintenance, routes, costs,
and even city infrastructure.
Now to give you an idea
of how hard that can be,
Daniel's previous life
was implementing machine
learning on brain images.
So not exactly a brain
surgeon, but more the person
telling the brain surgeon
what needs to happen.
So getting around
the side, the theme
of what we'll be rolling
through is how Daniel and Geotab
were able to use Google
Cloud's analytic tools
to make their analysis of
their business run easier.
Or in their words, "Don't
sweat the big stuff.
Make it Google's problem."
So let's take a look at the
agenda for this session.
We'll start by
kicking things off
with a brief
overview of BigQuery.
Then I'll pass things off to
Daniel for the exciting piece
of the conversation.
And at the end, we'll
bring things back around
and ask Daniel a few follow-up
questions about his work.
So let's go ahead
and get started
with BigQuery, the real time
cloud-scale data warehouse.
Now, when it comes
to analytics, we've
seen advancements across
different types of databases,
data lakes, data engineering
tools, business intelligence,
and more.
But the reality is that
the data warehouse still
forms the foundation
for analytics programs
across most businesses.
This is important to recognize
because it highlights the need
to bring users new capabilities.
Not just through new tools,
but through new features
in their existing
tools, particularly
the data warehouse.
Now, when we think
of BigQuery, it's
helpful to compare and contrast
it with the traditional EDW
environments.
And those were traditionally
complicated to get data into,
restricted to only a
few users, optimized
for old fashioned
business intelligence,
optimized for batch data.
They were in need of
constant patching,
and you needed quite
a few administrators
for the operational tasks.
Now, when you hear
from Daniel shortly,
you'll immediately know
that this kind of tech
wasn't going to work for Geotab.
Now, when we look
at BigQuery, it
comes at this space from a
very different perspective.
We automate delivery
into the data warehouse.
We make insights accessible
through the ability
to scale out that
data warehouse.
We enable ML and AI from
within the data warehouse,
and BigQuery can do
this all in real time
while protecting your data
and simplifying operations.
So when you bring
this all together,
it has a dramatic
impact on your business.
And that dramatic impact
is just how much time,
you're able to spend generating
analysis and insights.
When Daniel talks about
not sweating the big stuff,
it's a lot of what you
see in this gray area
from traditional
data warehouses.
Difficult people,
intensive processes.
They're about technology
and not about insights.
Now from Google
Cloud's perspective,
we think the hard part
is the applied analysis
and the insights our customers,
like Geotab, are generating.
We're happy to handle the
backend technology part
and let customers focus on
analyzing the specific domains
that they know like nobody else.
Now, before I pass
things off to Daniel,
I'd like to quickly highlight
a unique feature of BigQuery
that, when combined
with BigQuery ML,
helps make some of
Geotab's analysis possible.
And that's BigQuery GIS.
Now, many people
know Google's long
been an innovator and
a leader in geodata
with more than a billion people
using Google Maps each month.
With BigQuery GIS,
Google Cloud makes
it possible to do core GIS
functions directly in BigQuery
with familiar SQL statements.
So with that, I
finished off serving up
the appetizer for
this session, and we
can move on to the main
course that everyone's
been waiting for.
I'm going to pass
things off to Daniel,
who's going to take you through
how he and Geotab have put
Google's technology to
work in building out
an impressive business.
DANIEL LEWIS: Thanks Ryan.
So at Geotab we make
Internet of things devices.
These little
hardware devices that
plug into the OBD-II port
in vehicles to enable smart
telematics solutions.
I'm talking about
telematics solutions
generally that's for fleets,
and these little devices
are used to track
those vehicles.
And help companies
make better decisions
for managing their
individual vehicles,
and ultimately
operational efficiencies
across their entire fleet.
So we got a pretty small
data science team at Geotab,
though it's grown significantly
in the last couple of years.
But we're able to do so
much for our customers
because we can rely
on Google to handle
all of the big backend stuff,
and allow us to really focus on
spending time to solve
our customer's business
problems and our own
internal business problems.
So today we're going
to talk about going
from all of those individual
telematics devices,
and the customer level to
how you can bubble that
up using Google's
awesome scalable
backend tools to
produce globally
scalable analytics leveraging
the whole Google Cloud
ecosystem of tools.
So as of today,
we've got devices
installed in more than
two million vehicles
around the world.
And as I'm talking, you can look
at this really beautiful map
in the background, which shows
just a single day of vehicle
coverage in North America
from our connected devices.
So these devices are
constantly streaming data back
about the vehicle's position,
its speed, its acceleration,
the RPMs, engine
status information,
cooling temperature, oil
temperature, fault codes.
There's an onboarding
accelerometer.
We're going to be
adding a gyroscope.
And just tons of information
constantly streaming back.
Now, server side, this results
in over 40 billion data points
per day, which is just terabytes
of information at our end
is constantly streaming.
So managing the
streaming process alone,
that's already a huge
scalability challenge.
It's one that we solve
with Google's tools,
among many other problems
that we've encountered.
But due to time
limitations today, we're
just going to
focus on what we do
after we get all of that data,
which is where my job really
comes in and the part that
I get really excited about
and find really interesting.
So what do we actually
do with all of this data?
These 40 billion data
points that we're
getting every single day.
So 40 billion data
points is really great.
It's awesome.
I love working with
that amount of data,
but just the data sitting
there is not actionable
in any way for anybody.
No human can go in and just you
look through that information
and try to parse in, get
anything actionable out
of it just by looking at it.
So what we want to
provide to our customers
are things like solutions.
Something that actually
solves the business problem
using that data.
We do a lot of
things focused around
a few different key areas.
Some of them that are really
interesting for our fleet
customers are predictive
maintenance solutions,
preventing breakdowns
before they happen,
predicting battery failures,
that kind of thing.
These roadside breakdowns
are very expensive.
We want to use all this data
that's coming off the engine
to prevent that from happening.
We do things like artificial
intelligence driven smarter
fleet management.
And today's focus is going to
be more on the broader network
scale of things, so Smart City
Analytics and solutions to make
less congested and just
generally more efficient
cities around the world.
Which is a win-win for
everybody involved.
So why do we care
about congestion?
It's a really big problem.
If you're looking at
just North America,
congestion caused
urban Americans--
so not even all of America,
just urban regions--
to travel an extra 8.8 billion
hours-- this was in 2019--
for a congestion cost
$166 billion dollars.
So it's a bit of a problem.
And these are just
numbers for America.
It's an even bigger
problem globally,
so we definitely
wanted to use something
to solve this, or make it a
little bit better if we can.
Now, there's 20,000
cities in America.
So most of them
are really small,
but it's still a lot of cities.
And there are multitudes
more around the world.
So it seems maybe a little
bit intractable to start
thinking about how we can
optimize infrastructure
across 20,000, 30,000,
100,000 cities,
but little small improvements
really do matter.
They can scale.
You can make these
little bit baby changes
and across hundreds of
thousands of individuals,
you can wind up with really
big cumulative impacts.
So just an example
in San Francisco.
I looked up the numbers
there, and we've
got a few 100,000
people entering
cars in San Francisco
every single day
on their way to work.
And if they have to stop at only
five individual intersections
in the city, and we're somehow
able to shave three seconds
off their average
stop time, we're
going to save 375 hours of
idling every single day,
giving each commuter an
hour of their life back.
This is great for the commuter,
it's great for the city.
Getting more people through
with less congestion.
Less impacts on the environment.
It's a win-win for
everybody involved.
In order to improve
anything though,
we need to know what
the current reality is.
We need to know what
the current state is
so that we can push
forward in a direction
that we want to improve in.
We have to start
with data and we
have to start with
a lot of it, as you
saw from our previous slide.
So here's an example
of the type of thing
that we might want to
produce for a city.
So on the left there you can
see a heat map of downtown San
Francisco, and the
heat map is just
colored by the average wait
time in seconds for a given
hour of the day in the city.
Now, imagine that you could just
zoom into any city in the world
and access this kind
of detailed information
for every single
intersection in that city
without any kind of
infrastructure changes.
No camera
installation, no strips
to lay down, no trenches
to dig and put strips in.
No one's standing at the
corner with a clipboard
and a stopwatch, which
in talking to cities,
amazingly this still happens.
Imagine you could just get
all this information instantly
from all of the cars that
are already driving around.
You don't have to do anything.
This is really what
we're trying to achieve,
and this is what you
can do when you leverage
Google Cloud because of
the volumes of information
that we're able to
handle with that backend.
So to achieve this goal in
this particular talk here,
we're going to restrict the
scope a little bit to something
a little bit more
manageable, and that's
going to be focusing on signal
controlled intersections.
So these are the things that
the city can tweak immediately
to get some short-term
feedback on impacts,
and iteratively move
towards a better solution.
So this is the kind
of thing that we're
thinking about when we're
talking about traffic light
optimizations.
Going in and removing a stop
sign, or adding a stop sign,
or adding or removing lanes,
adding dedicated right turn
lanes.
Coming up with
diamond interchanges,
these kind of things.
Total infrastructure changes
are things that you definitely
have to consider, and
they have large impacts
on traffic congestion.
But they're not something
that can be easily or cheaply
manipulated or changed.
With traffic signals,
you can make improvements
with just the lights though.
If we're looking at
something simple,
like a North-South or
East-West direction
intersection like
we've got here,
how much green do you
allocate to each direction?
That's an optimization problem.
If you're going
to a 72nd, 142nd,
whatever it is life
cycle time, there's
only a certain amount
of green that can be
allocated in either direction.
If you give it more
in one direction,
it has to be taken from
the other direction,
and that has impacts
upstream and downstream.
So how do you actually
know what's better?
And is the problem
at this intersection,
or is it upstream or downstream
of this intersection?
On a particular
day, is it because
of the normal cyclical
traffic flows,
or is it because of an
accident, et cetera?
We have a lot of data
to be able to determine
what the optimal light timing
actually is for any given
intersection, and what the
impacts would be on the network
if we were to change it.
So that's the type of
question that we're
trying to answer with our data.
However, streaming a lot of
data is very, very expensive.
So it's getting
cheaper all the time.
And when you're talking
about millions of vehicles
constantly streaming data,
those little bits of cost
add up pretty quickly.
We can't do continuous
data sampling.
We've got real devices,
real hardware limitations,
with local storage
limitations, as well,
real data transfer costs.
We need to figure out what
the ideal sample rate is.
So what's the ideal
sample rate so
that you don't miss, for
example, going around corners.
As you go around
a corner, there's
a lot of different
things happening.
We don't want to miss
the corner, et cetera,
so we had a higher
sample frequency
than if you're just going in a
straight line down a freeway,
for example.
If we were to constantly drop
points every tenth of a second
or something, we're
bringing back a lot
of redundant
information because we
know you're just going in a
straight line down the highway.
If you have a
uniform sample rate,
you can't really solve both of
those problems simultaneously.
If you crank up the
sample rate, especially
if you're catching
those corners,
you're going to be sending back
way more information that you
need in areas that you
don't actually need it.
We solve this at Geotab with
something called Curve Logic.
It's a simple but
very elegant idea
that we use to minimize
the data transfer costs.
We've got a couple patents
on it listed there.
And the basic idea
is really simple.
You can watch the cool
animation there on the right
while I describe it.
But essentially, you just
have a high frequency sampling
on the actual hardware
device, and then that's
stored in a local
storage buffer.
Before you send that back,
you go through that buffer
and you choose points from
the sequence of high frequency
sampled points.
Such that linearly
interpolating between them,
which is what you see
with these red dots there,
no intervening dropped point
would be more than some
chosen error threshold
away from the line.
And that's just a parameter
that you can tweak
depending on your use case.
And then from the device
to the server, only
sending back those individual
points where we were linearly
interpolating between.
So only those red points
get sent back to the server.
So we use this technique
to really efficiently send
the minimal amount of
data back to our servers,
and it enables accurate
trip reconstruction.
So when you're going in a
straight line down the highway,
we may only need to drop
down one or two points
from your initial point in
order to tell that you're still
on that highway.
Then when you go
on the off-ramp,
we're going to drop a
whole bunch of points
and send those
back to the server
to make sure that we didn't miss
your turn off that off-ramp.
Now, when we do this
and we come back
and we start looking
at the data in BigQuery
and on our visualizer tools
and that kind of thing,
the first obvious thing
that's going to happen
is now we've got gaps.
So on the service
of all these gaps,
we know in reality,
you would have
had to have driven through
that little green circle,
that intersection
there, in order
to get from one side
of Fulton Street
to the other side
of Fulton Street.
So how are we going to fill in
all of these gaps server side?
We know that, because we did
the Curve Logic, that linearly
interpolating between
those two points,
we would have never been more
dense the error threshold
that we chose away from those.
So we've got our
two million vehicles
generating billions of points.
We know that in order
to fill them in,
we can just linearly
interpolate between them.
But with two million
vehicles, billions of points,
how are we going to actually
do that in a scalable way?
We don't want to just linearly
interpolate necessarily
at a huge resolution in
areas we don't need it again,
but we want to make sure we
don't miss the intersections.
In our particular
use case, because we
are focused on high
quality data production
for these intersections,
we're going
to drop them at a scale that
allows us to ensure that we've
got coverage in every single
geohash of interest, which I'll
get to later, to do
efficient spatial joins.
In our case, that's a little
bit under nine meters.
So we've got two
million vehicles,
40 billion points a day, we have
to fill in all of these gaps
at a resolution of nine meters.
As you can imagine, that's
a really difficult process,
involving connecting tons
of different systems,
trying to scale
out and parallelize
the interpretation, et cetera.
No, not at all.
Just kidding about that.
With Google you don't need
to sweat that big stuff.
End to end, we never
leave the Google ecosystem
for this project.
We just make the big stuff
Google's problem entirely.
Let them handle the
hard backend work.
So as you can see
on the slide there,
with the details
on the right, we
run a daily interpolation
for all of our vehicles.
And this actually runs
in less than 20 minutes.
All you have to do is work in
a little bit of the simple math
for the linearly interpolated
point dropping between our GPS
points.
And Google worries about
scaling all that out
on the backend in
a paralyzable way.
We never have to leave BigQuery.
It's really, really,
really simple.
So we've been able to minimize
our data transfer costs
and accurately reconstruct
the trips on the server side.
Now, the reason that
we're able to do
all of this super efficiently
is because of the tools
that Google has been
continually innovating.
And one of the things that
Ryan mentioned at the beginning
was BQGIS.
This was really a
game changer for us,
and enabling us to do
all of this scaling.
So July 2018, if I
remember correctly,
is when BigQuery released
native geospatial support.
This allowed us to move away
from relying on JavaScript DDS,
so those were really
powerful at the time
when we are using them.
But they don't scale out
as well on the backend
as native BigQuery functions.
So when we started
switching all of that
over to BQGIS functions, we
were able to really balloon
the scope that we were looking
at for those type of things.
And before we were running it
on a region to region basis,
and now we run this every
single day for the entire world.
We're constantly
leveraging BQGIS functions
and weaving them into
everything that we do.
So we've got all of our
data back from the vehicles,
we've reconstructed these trips,
and interpolated the points.
We've got all of the
locations at a very high
spatial resolution.
So what do we actually
want to do next?
We have this data, but
what we're trying to do
is find these intersections
so that we can track vehicles
through them.
Now, this is the tricky part.
So for a proof of concept
and for the purposes
of this presentation, we used
OpenStreetMap traffic signals
as our point of reference
to look for intersections.
So an intersection is not
something that's actually
generally well-defined in a
geometric sense in many mapping
solutions, and
particularly in OSM there's
a lot of possible configurations
for traffic lights and ways
to come into an intersection.
You can see a
sample of them here.
Sometimes you've got
two-ways and three lights.
Sometimes you've got four-ways
and one light, eight ways
and four lights.
There's a lot of
different configurations,
and there's no real concept
of the intersection itself.
Or if you imagine,
like the polygon
that would wrap
around the roads that
lead into that intersection.
And it's not so easy then to map
these kind of individual ways
and connected nodes
and lights to something
that has a geographic
representation of what
the intersection
actually is, in terms
of what a human would
understand, in terms
of behavior of cars through it.
So how do we go from some
number of traffic lights
and some number of
ways to a single point
and its associated geometry to
represent that intersection?
And the way that we
solve that is just
start with a really
simple algorithm DBSCAN.
So we're going to leverage
the DBSCAN algorithm, which
is really simple.
It's a really
powerful algorithm.
It's been used for
decades, and it's
really great at finding
local clusters of points.
However, even for this
really simple use case,
it really quickly becomes
a scalability problem.
So if we look at
the whole world,
OSM has about 1.2 million
traffic light nodes.
This leads us to 742 billion
pairwise combinations
of distances.
So if you had data storage
in a 64-bit numpy array,
that's more than 5 1/2 terabytes
of RAM already needed just
to store the distance matrix
before you started doing any
calculations.
So on top of that, DBSCAN is
not a really easy algorithm
to parallelize, so I'm
starting to sweat a bit.
This doesn't really
seem tractable.
How are we going to do this?
There must be some way that we
can make this Google's problem,
and there definitely is.
So we can solve this actually
pretty easily with Dataflow.
Now, Dataflow is great at
having this kind of stuff
in the backend.
So let's utilize some
of the information
that we have about the
connectivity of these lights.
We're not going in blind here.
So we know that some of
them are in certain ways.
Those ways are
connected to other ways.
And those ways have lights
on them, some of them
don't, et cetera.
So we know something
about the relationship
between the nodes and the
ways and how they're connected
and the street network.
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to utilize those
connectivity relationships
to reduce the search space
around each light, where it's
only calculating
distances to lights that
are within some number
of connectivity hops
to the light itself.
Plus some other
connectivity parameters
that we introduce, such as the
type of road and street names,
that type of things.
These are all
hyperparameters that we
can tune in our approach, but
assume that we've done that
and this leads us to a markedly
reduced number of pre-clusters.
And with those
pre-clusters we can then
run a paralyzed DBSCAN.
So when we do this approach,
we get about 1.6 million
pre-clusters to
perform DBSCAN on.
Each of those are
independent of each other
though, so this means that
we can now parallelize it.
And on average they have
nine points or less,
which is a much more
attractive problem for DBSCAN,
it's a much smaller
paralyzed distance matrix.
So we can basically just
throw it some data for now
and let it handle all the
hard work of paralyzing
this across all these
1.6 million clusters
on the backend.
Let it scale up
the machines, let
it worry about how to
distribute the work.
How to collect it after
it, how to stream it
back into BigQuery.
All I had to do is
figure out the approach.
So we're able to
really easily do this,
and this runs pretty fast.
So now we've identified
700,000 intersections
in the entire world in
less than 10 minutes
using just BigQuery
and Dataflow.
So this is excellent.
We still haven't left the core
Google Cloud product suite.
So now we can go on
to the next step,
which is mapping the roads.
So once we have
the intersections,
we have to accurately
map the roads in order
to accurately track where
the vehicles are actually
coming from and going to so
that we can get accurate metrics
at a per-intersection level.
And ultimately
chain them together
to get quarter analytics and
a broader network effects
as well.
So in order to efficiently
generate these trips,
we want to be able to do a
very simple geospatial join.
So if we were to do something
like a simple naive cross
join between all
of our GPS points
and all of the
roads in the world,
and maybe use something like a
BQGIS function like ST_DWithin.
We'd have an absolutely
astronomical number of roads.
So this is not possible
even for Google yet.
It's far more than
BigQuery can handle.
So there has to be
a better smarter way
that we can figure out what
road you're on really quickly
in a scalable way
for these millions
and millions of vehicles and
these billions of points.
And there's a lot of smarter
ways that we could do this.
And at Geotab we
tend to use Geohash
for geocoding latitude
and longitude.
So Geohash is just a
Z-order space filling curve.
You can think of it, if
you haven't used it before,
something just like
nested rectangles
that cover the whole globe.
Any two latitude
and longitude pair
inside one of these
little rectangular boxes
gets assigned a string
which is unique to that box.
And there's a lot of
other mapping systems,
such as S2 cells,
H3 cells, et cetera,
but at Geotab we
tend to use Geohash,
and it has native supporting
BQGIS, which is great.
We don't have to jump
over to JavaScript DDS.
So this allows us to forget
about the impossibility
of accurately joining
floats and the impossibility
of doing these cross joins.
It enables us to do a
very fast straight string
join based on Geohash.
So that's great, but that then
leads us into another problem.
So if we're going to be doing
the straight join in Geohash,
we have to then know which
geohashes are actually
part of the road network and
which parts of the road network
are associated with
which intersection.
So there are some machine
learning approaches
that we've used, but there are
actually some simpler cleverer
ways that you can do leveraging
the ability of BigQuery scale
really efficiently
before you even
have to get into the
machine learning area.
So the hard part.
Back to the problem, which
is really a trip generation
problem.
In order to generate
trips, again, we
need to know the set
of possible traversals
that is through any
given intersection
to segment the vehicle path
into intersection-based trips.
So before we even think about
associating the geohashes
with the ways, we need to
know which ways are associated
with the intersection.
So as a first step,
we can just pull all
the directly connected ways
out of the intersection,
so anything that's directly
touching or connected
to a traffic light.
So you can see an example
of that on the bottom right
at the slide for some
random intersection
that I just picked.
However, you can
only see on the map
the adjacent intersections
to the left, right, North,
and South are further away than
those ways that are extending.
So we've got these
directly connected ways
but they don't actually
map all the way
to the next intersection.
So if you were to just
base trips on this,
they're not actually going
to be accurately reflecting
the metrics for those vehicles.
They're only going to
be counting vehicles
that are on those
lines, assuming
we've done the geohash
associated with those lines.
So we miss all of the
intervening information
from when you left the
previous intersection
until you get to these short
distance approaches here.
So that's something we're
going to have to fix.
So what we actually
need to do is
start with all of those
directly connected ways,
and then somehow get all
the ways connected to those.
And then all the ways
connected to those, and those,
and so on and so forth.
Going backwards until
we either run out
of ways that are connected or
we hit the next intersection,
while simultaneously
somehow taking
care not to include side streets
and different types of roads
and things like that.
So you can see with the code
on the bottom right there,
it's actually pretty easy to
get all the connected ways.
It's a really simple
join on the nodes.
There's nothing really
challenging about that.
So this is ultimately
what we want to do.
You can see there's 132
connected ways here.
So we've got our simple
query to join back and get
the connected ways.
In this particular case, we
know how many hours so we're
good to go, right?
We just keep joining
until we've got
all these ways that
are highlighted here
for this intersection.
But of course, it's
never quite that easy.
So we don't know a priori
for any given intersection
how many ways are connected, so
we don't know how many times we
need to actually join.
So what we're
going to have to do
is look recursively until
we run out of connections.
In order to scale,
we know we want
to do this recursion in
BigQuery and just leverage SQL.
Unfortunately you can't
do recursion in SQL, so
what are we going to do?
Or can we?
So I'm super excited about
this and it's really recent.
So in November 2019 BigQuery
released native scripting
support, which is really
amazing and powerful
and allows you to do
really quick prototyping,
experimenting, and iteration
of things that weren't really
possible before
right inside BigQuery
and right inside the UI,.
So you can run
scripts via API, just
like a run of the
mill SQL query,
you could run it in the UI.
It's got all the
basic building blocks
as well that you would want
in a scripting language,
like conditional execution,
loops, we can mix DML and SQL.
It gives us some really
powerful capabilities,
and we're going to leverage
all those capabilities to solve
this connectivity problem.
So I was really
excited this came out,
and I immediately ran
over to the documentation.
And unfortunately, the
documentation for this
is super underwhelming,
and they actually
are really underselling
the power and capability
of this tool.
So if you see on the
left there, that's
the example for loops
in the documentation.
No, we're never going
to use SQL to increment
some random variable X and spit
it out at the end of the loop.
This is just not a use
case that would happen.
This is really the extent
of the documentation
that they have for loops,
so I wanted to do something
a little more fun
to learn it and then
also showcase the power of it.
So I went and tried to
implement a recursive Fibonacci
generator using nothing
but SQL and BigQuery,
and the result is
here on the left.
It totally works.
I wouldn't recommend doing
recursive Fibonacci in general,
and definitely
don't do it in SQL.
But the point is that this
is a really powerful tool,
and the things that
you would think
are not going to be
possible to implement in SQL
and weren't before, you can now
do really easily in BigQuery.
And you can copy the
code there on the left
if you want and run it.
It totally works.
It's going to get scaling
problems at some point
as it explodes recursively,
but the point is that it works.
And when we implement
this in a smarter way,
we can solve things like
our connected ways problem
without ever leaving
the SQL environment,
and letting Google handle all
that big complicated backend
stuff.
So here's some
actually usable codes.
On the left there
is the final code
that I wrote to actually do this
with a SQL scripted approach.
So what we can do is we
can build a while loop that
just keeps joining
backwards and keeps
joining backwards on way nodes
until we can't find anymore.
So it's a really
simple while loop.
We can set some break
condition if we want.
15, 30, 100, whatever we like
in terms of number of connected
hops.
And insert the results of each
step into our reference table
at the end of a loop iteration.
And at the start of a loop,
we just join back on it
with the ways and nodes until
the next loop iteration.
We just keep doing this
and we just keep doing this
until we hit our break
limit or until the table
size stops changing.
We know that we've run
out of connected ways.
So once you bring in the
ability to leverage loops,
this actually becomes a really
simple problem to solve.
We just take our simple
join and we recursively
iterate it until we run
out of connectivity.
And then you can
just lean on BigQuery
and it's awesome
ability to scale.
And this whole thing actually
runs in less than an hour
for the entire world.
So Google handles the
paralyzation on the backend
really, really well.
So here's the results of that
in a particular neighborhood.
This is just Oakville
where I live.
And this has been done
for the entire world,
so we've got every single
connected way associated
with every single
intersection in the world.
So this is really fantastic,
and in combination with the data
flow step that we did before
and the couple of BigQuery step,
we're still under two hours
end to end to do all this.
To get all the connected ways
associated with intersections
for the entire planet.
So what do we
actually do with it?
So we have the roads,
but this doesn't actually
solve the problem yet.
We still need all of
those associated geohashes
and we're back to our
original cross join problem.
Except instead of geographic
points, we now have geohashes.
So we still can't just
join these geohashes
on the roads, that geohashes
that cover the whole planet
and figure out which
road they're on.
So we still got 20 billion
geohashes and 18 million ways
after the reduction step.
That's still a 386
quintillion row cross join.
That's still way too much
for BigQuery to handle,
so again, we need to come up
with a smarter more clever way
to do this.
Now, Google's really
good at scaling,
which is the point I'm
trying to drive home
in this presentation.
So if you can craft a
problem in such a way
that the hard part
is scaling, at least
within astronomical
limits, you pretty much
won because Google can just
handle all that for you.
So let's do that.
So let's think a little bit
more carefully about the problem
and create it in such a way
that we're stuck on a scaling
problem, and then just
throw it at Google
and let it deal
with that for us.
So what we can do is actually
break this problem down
into two primary steps.
First, what we need is actually
a subset of close-by geohashes.
From there we can restrict the
set of geohashes in some way
so those will just
cover the road.
And then we are back to
our original problem,
where we have [INAUDIBLE] GPS
points, because we can easily
get geohashes for those
points directly with BQGIS.
It's just a straight join.
We don't cross join
required anymore.
And now we've got
something that's
going to work
really well and it's
going to scale really well.
So we can't just geohash the
nodes that make up the ways.
Those are unevenly
spaced on the road
so we're going to get gaps.
We could start with
that maybe and look
at parent nodes and neighbor
nodes, parent neighbor
geohashes, et cetera.
We're going to have a lot of
edge cases to deal with there,
and those arrays don't
scale super well.
We know the cross joins are
going to work, so how are we
going to actually do this?
So what we need to do is make
some sort of search space
ourselves.
We can do this using just
SQL UDFs and BQGIS again.
So all we really
need to start with
is some reduced
search space, which
we can visualize
as a bounding box
with some incremental
spacing from one side
of the bounding box to another.
This gives us basically
a matrix of possibilities
of lat long points that
we stepped through.
And we convert each of those
into a geohash using BQGIS,
and then only retain
those geohashes
that are within some
distance of the road.
We can let Google then
handle the big stuff, which
is scaling out this approach
to the entire world.
So this is the result of
our first pass on a randomly
selected road.
What we've done is surrounded
this particular road
with a bounding box, which
you can see on the left there.
It's very easy to
do just by getting
the extense of the geometry
and adding some buffer space.
And then we have this
wrapped box around the road.
And then we simply use
BigQuery to generate an array,
where we step by
an amount smaller
than the geohash
dimensions of interest.
And I'm taking into
account the distance
from the equator, because
they're not perfectly linear,
the Earth is not flat.
And then we geocode these points
of not long into our greater
geohashes and then voila,
we've covered the whole road
with geohashes.
So from there we can now finally
do our ST_DWithin function
that we were talking
about several slides ago.
That's just a singular geometry
comparison for each way
and it's potentially
associated geohashes.
Instead of this massive cross
join, which is impossible.
So now we've done this
ST_DWithin function,
and we've got all of
the geohashes that
are covering the road.
We get the estimated
road width based
on things like the
number of lanes,
the geographical
region of interest,
the prescribed maximum amount
of roadways for a given
municipality, et cetera.
And we've got some
models that do that.
And now we've got a wonderfully
reduced set of geohashes
that accurately covers
the road itself.
So once we parallelize this
a few times with [INAUDIBLE],,
this actually runs in
less than four hours
for the entire planet.
So here's an example of
just all of the intersection
roads in Singapore for fun.
And so remember that we never
left BigQuery for any of this.
I never looked at any
data from Singapore.
I mean, I picked a
few local examples.
Figured out how to
best cleverly come up
with a process that leverages
the ability of BigQuery
to scale.
And then we're going
from basically a text
string representing the
geography of a roadway, which
is stored in BigQuery, without
any direct relationship
to the intersection, to a set
of all the geohashes covering
all the roads in
the entire world
the lead up into a particular
intersection using nothing
but SQL.
And we still spend for
this whole pipeline
only around six hours
from end and to run.
So all in a day's work we've
gone from some simple text
strings to
representative geohashes
covering the entire planet.
So now we can
actually go and start
generating metrics
for the cities.
And this was the purpose
of doing all of this
to begin with.
So since we have intersections
with labels and all
of the associated geohashes now,
their centers, their bounds,
et cetera, all we have to do
is geocode our vehicle path GPS
points into geohashes, and then
join back on this intersections
table that we created.
From there we can easily
assign each portion of a trip
to the intersection that
it passes through next.
And from there it's
a simple matter
of tracking things like
speed, the number of stops,
the idle time, the
idle time per stop,
the total distance traveled from
the point from which you first
stopped, which we can
use to infer cue links
and things like that.
To pull out really
any metric of interest
and subsequently aggregate up
to the time period of interest.
So if you imagine, you're
traveling out of your driveway
and you get onto the road.
And at some point
on that road, you're
going to hit an
intersection where
you have to make a turn decision
or a straight through decision.
So the point from which
you leave that driveway
and to the point which you
get to that intersection
is going to be one subset
of your total trip.
That subset has a bunch of
metrics associated with it
and get associated
with that intersection
that you then pass through.
From the moment that you
leave that intersection,
we start counting again
towards the next intersection
that you experience,
and so on and so forth.
Then we break up
all of your driving
into these little trip
segments that are associated
with a given intersection.
An example there on
the right there is just
for the region of Toronto.
So using that
aggregated information,
we can now really
easily generate
all sorts of insights for any
city where we've got vehicles.
And as you saw in one of
our first slides there,
that's pretty much any
city in North America.
And we're expanding
globally as well.
So you can see some cool
examples on the slide here.
So on the left, we've
got the average trip
volume for heavy duty vehicles.
You can see that
they tend to prefer
certain quarters
through the city,
and this is the
Las Vegas region.
On the top right, from
Las Vegas as well,
we've got a quarter analysis
heat map of individual trips
through a sequence
of intersection.
And this essentially
shows you the propensity
to have to stop at any given
intersection along the quarter.
On the bottom right is just
a simple heat map example
showing the
percentage of vehicles
that have to stop at any given
intersection based on the turn
direction.
If you'll look closely, you can
see some interesting patterns
there, like rush
hour times, depending
on the direction at certain
times a day, around 8:00
AM and around 5:00 and 6:00 PM.
And at the bottom there, you can
actually see two right turns.
One of which has a
significantly higher propensity
to stop than the other one.
And if you go and
look on the map,
it's because that turn direction
has a dedicated right turn lane
and the other one doesn't.
So the one where you
don't have to stop
has a dedicated turn lane.
And those things
like that are really
easy to pick out
of these things,
and really validate the
infrastructure changes
that you've been making.
And then with this
kind of information,
we can roll it up to any
time period of interest.
So you could do, for
example, a few week period
before a light change,
change the light timing,
and then look at a
few week period after.
And measure if there
were any differences.
And doing this throughout
the entire city
and looking at the
network effects
upstream and downstream,
you can really
start to optimize, and
shave off those few seconds
that we were talking about
that gives people back
time and money of their day.
And really helps reduce
the environmental impact
of idling and congestion.
So that ends the tech
portion of our talk here.
And I want to jump
into a Q&A with Ryan.
So he's scripted some
questions that he didn't really
share with me beforehand.
He wanted it to
be a real live Q&A
to give you the feel of
actually being with us here
as an audience.
RYAN LIPPERT: OK.
Thanks Daniel,
and thanks so much
for sharing everything there.
The stuff that you and Geotab
are doing is really impressive.
And I think, as you mentioned,
it was a little bit more
on the technical side by
design, the conversation
that you just had there
with the listeners.
Can you talk a little bit more
about what the benefits are
on the business side for your
customers and how that works?
DANIEL LEWIS: Yeah, absolutely.
So I mean, this impacts
of this particular project
that we worked on--
I mean, we do a
lot of other things
as well-- but I'd also just
say that a lot of our customers
actually are cities, and have
their municipal vehicles hooked
up with our IoT device.
So that being said
though, there's
a lot of impacts for
our fleet customers
as well from
something like this.
So if you're going to do
heavy duty vehicle driving
around the city, every
time you have to stop,
that idling uses up fuel.
It also takes a lot longer
for a heavy duty vehicle
to accelerate again.
That uses up fuel and driver
time and things like that.
And then from a
city's perspective,
when that big truck has to
stop and then accelerate again,
that causes congestion.
So it's a win for the city by
reducing congestion, reducing
emissions, idling,
things like that.
But it's also just a
win for our customers
in having to spend less
gas and waiting less time.
And when you think about
one individual truck,
it maybe doesn't seem
that big of a deal.
But if you think back to
the San Francisco example
with 450,000 cars-- so
most of our customers
don't have that many,
but some of them
definitely do have 5, 10,
20,000 vehicles-- if you imagine
these little stops constantly
across all these cities, when
you've got 10,000, 20,000
trucks driving every single day,
these little
improvements, they really
add up if you can make
those small changes.
And then speaking with certain
cities, so you saw on the map
before of Las Vegas, there
are some corridors that trucks
like to travel down.
And a city, once they have
this kind of information,
can start to think about
things like freight signal
prioritization.
So because these trucks take
a lot longer to accelerate,
there's a larger
congestion impact
from them having to stop.
So if you're a city who
wanted to prioritize freight
along a certain corridor and
minimize the congestion impact,
you can do things like give an
extra couple seconds of green
when a truck is approaching
to let it go through.
So obviously, this is
a win for the customer
because they don't
have to stop as much.
And it's a win for the city not
having to reduce congestion.
RYAN LIPPERT: I
don't think there's
any of us who
wouldn't rather have
less congestion on
the streets, and so I
think that's a win for just
about everyone out there.
You mentioned that you're
staying within Google Cloud
as you do this
and it's BigQuery,
there's some Dataflow in there.
Can you help describe
to our listeners
out there what it would take
if you didn't have BigQuery
and the surrounding tools?
DANIEL LEWIS: Yeah, absolutely.
So I think a lot
of it would be what
you mentioned at the beginning.
If we didn't have all of
this amazing infrastructure
on the backend to do the scaling
and manage all that for us,
we'd have to spend a lot
more time in that gray area,
and actually managing
and building out
the infrastructure.
And that's not really where
our data scientist skills
or expertise lies,
at least not for me.
My expertise and my value add
is in solving these business
problems for people.
And if I had to spend
80%, 90% of my time
doing out the infrastructure,
the installation probably
wouldn't be as good because
I can't devote as much time
to it.
So what we probably
would have done then
is using the tools that we had.
If we didn't have all this
amazing ability to scale,
just really reduce
the scope down.
We maybe would have had to do
it neighborhood by neighborhood
or maybe city by
city, and come up
with other kind of limitations
to restrict the amount of data
that's going in just because we
wouldn't be able to handle it.
But because we're able
to, we're able to do
this globally,
which helps us to be
a much more powerful product.
RYAN LIPPERT:
Makes sense Daniel.
So hey, as we wrap up, do
you have any parting words
for the listeners out there?
Advice on how to try
out new features?
I saw how fast you put
scripting into production.
I thought that was really great.
Any tips for the
listeners out there?
DANIEL LEWIS: Yeah, absolutely.
So I know I poked fun a bit at
that documentation in the talk
there.
And some of it has some
things I like to make fun of,
but overall Google's
documentation is actually
really, really good.
So when the new
features come out,
I dive into the
documentation right away.
I pull out the examples,
I try to implement them.
I try to implement them
against my own data,
so everybody watching.
Your experts in your own data.
You know where your bottlenecks
and your problems are.
Think about ways
that you can leverage
these new tools that are coming
out on your own data sets.
And if you're not
quite there yet,
BigQuery has got a lot of
sample data sets in there
and you can play
around with those.
But really need to
start digging in
and applying it
to actual problems
to understand the new
techniques, the new tools,
and their capabilities.
And once you do, it's
almost always the case
that you can really quickly
implement it in production
and get some really big
wins, like we did with BQGIS
and like we did with
SQL scripting as well.
And Google's also got some
lots of great champions,
like Fullybay and [INAUDIBLE],,
and that are constantly
pushing out content about
how to use these new tools
with examples given.
And if you can just go
and replicate their work,
start making tweaks, thinking
about how to apply it
to your own data,
you can actually
get ramped up pretty quickly
with all of this stuff.
That would be my advice.
RYAN LIPPERT:
Daniel, great advice
to go along with a
great presentation.
I can't thank you enough
for coming and sharing
your thoughts today and
what you're doing at Geotab.
And just wish both
you and Geotab
the best of luck going forward.
DANIEL LEWIS: Thanks Ryan.